>> Tucker: LAST NIGHT WE
INTRODUCED YOU TO THE LATEST
ADDITION TO OUR GLOBAL FAMILY OF
NATIONS, THE HUNDRED AND 96
COUNTRY ON EARTH, WHERE KEEPING
TRACK, IT’S CALLED CHAZ, THE
GLEAMING CAPITAL ARISES FROM
LAND THAT ONCE BELONGED TO AN
INDIGENOUS BUT NOW NEARLY
EXTINCT TRIBE IS KNOWN AS THE
SEATTLE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AS WITH SO MANY GREAT NATIONS,
THE CREATION STORY HOLDS
INNUMERABLE LESSONS FOR ALL OF
US, IN A TALE OF UNLIKELY GOOD
FORTUNE AND THE TRIUMPH OF
PERSEVERANCE OVER HARDSHIP.
HOW DO PEOPLE WITH NO USEFUL
SKILLS, NO RECORD OF ACHIEVEMENT
OR PERSONAL HYGIENE, A GROUP
CAPABLE OF SMASHING WINDOWS AND
SETTING FIRES BUT NOTHING ELSE,
HOW DO A GROUP LIKE THAT CREATE
AN ENTIRELY NEW NATION?
THAT’S A QUESTION WE MAY SOON
FACE HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
IN FACT GIVEN OUR CURRENT
TRAJECTORY.
IT’S NEVER EASY TO BUILD THINGS
THAT PEOPLE CAN ONLY DESTROY BUT
CHAZ PULLED IT OFF WITH GRIT AND
DETERMINATION, THIS PLUCKY
LITTLE NATION MANAGED TO GIVE
BIRTH TO ITSELF AND IN THE
PROCESS A WHOLE NEW ERA OF
DEMOCRATIC SELF-GOVERNANCE.
OKAY, THAT’S OVERSTATEMENT, THEY
HAVEN’T ACTUALLY BUILT ANYTHING,
IT’S STILL MOSTLY GRAFFITI AND
DISCARDED STARBUCKS CUPS.
NOR IS IT FOLIO DEMOCRACY, THE
COUNTRY IS RUN BY A WORLD WAR
CLASS WRAPPER, HE IS IN OTHER
WORDS WORK IN PROGRESS.
BUT CHAZ DOES HAVE ONE
FUNCTIONING INSTITUTION, A
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE THAT’S
UP AND RUNNING, PROUD,
INDEPENDENT PEOPLE AND THEY PLAN
TO SEE THEMSELVES.
TAKE A LOOK AT CHAZ’S FIRST
COLLECTIVE FARM.
IT’S NOT KANSAS AT HARVEST TIME
BUT IT’S A START, THE FARMERS OF
CHAZ HAVE BIG DREAMS, THEY
IMAGINE SEVERAL MORE SQUARE FEET
OF KALE AND ORGANIC SCALLIONS
PLANTED IN DIXIE CUPS AND OF
COURSE CANNABIS, LOTS AND LOTS
OF STINKY INDICA BUDS FOR THE
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE HEART, AS THEY OFTEN
SAY, IF THEY COULD DO IT IN
JONESTOWN, WE CAN DO IT HERE.
NATURALLY OFFICIALS IN NEARBY
WASHINGTON STATE HAVE BECOME
BITTERLY JEALOUS OF THIS
THRIVING BREAKAWAY REPUBLIC.
TWO DAYS AGO, THE SMALL MINDED
GOVERNOR OF WASHINGTON PRETENDED
HE HAD NEVER EVEN HEARD OF CHAZ.
>> I’D LIKE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
WHAT’S GOING ON IN SEATTLE, THE
CAPITOL HILL AUTONOMOUS ZONE,
WHAT’S YOUR THOUGHT ON THE FACT
THAT THE PROTESTERS HAVE TAKEN
OUT OVER AND ARE NOT ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO COME IN?
>> WELL, THAT’S NEWS TO ME SO I
WILL HAVE TO RESERVE ANY COMMENT
ABOUT IT, I HAVE NOT HEARD
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: NEVER HEARD OF
CHAZ?
AS IF.
COME ON, GOVERNOR, SHOW US THE
SEARCH HISTORY ON YOUR PHONE,
EVERY IDEALISTIC YOUNG PIONEER
IN THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN COMPULS
GOOGLING CHAZ FOR DAYS AND YOU
HAVEN’T?
RIDICULOUS.
THE MEDIA, MEANWHILE, NOT
SURPRISINGLY, HAVE MISSED THE
STORY COMPLETELY.
THEY ARE PRETENDING THAT CHAZ
ISN’T EVEN A REAL COUNTRY, THEY
ARE CALLING IT A STREET FAIR.
>> HUNDREDS OF DEMONSTRATORS ARE
BEING GATHERED AND WHAT IS BEING
CALLED PART STREET PROTEST DON’T
COME APART STREET FESTIVAL.
>> YOU COULD CALL IT A COMMUNITY
TAKEOVER.
SUGGESTING THAT THE U.S.
MILITARY WOULD USE FORCE.
THIS IS THE CAPITOL HILL
NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE HEART OF
SEATTLE, WERE TALKING ABOUT A
SIX BLOCK AREA.
IT’S MUCH MORE OF A PEDESTRIAN
STREET FAIR TYPE ATMOSPHERE, THE
FOOD TRUCKS ARE OPEN, THE
FAVORITE TACO SHOP IS OPEN,
THERE’S COUCHES OUT THERE.
>> Tucker: FOOD TRUCKS AND A
TACO SHOP.
THE PEOPLE ON TELEVISION PRETEND
THIS PROUD, INDEPENDENT NATION
IS SOME TYPE OF ETHNIC FOOD
FESTIVAL.
NO CORPORATE STOOGES, THIS ISN’T
ABOUT PINATA’S AND DUNK TANKS,
THIS IS NATIONHOOD.
CHAZ HAS TEETH, CHAZ CAN BITE
BACK.
>> THEY WANT TO SEE THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT DEFUNDED OR EVEN
ABOLISHED.
SHORT OF SOME TYPE OF MAJOR
CONCESSION THEY’RE NOT GOING TO
LEAVE VOLUNTARILY AND WE SHOULD
POINT OUT THAT WASHINGTON IS AN
OPEN CARRY STATE AND NO DOUBT
SOME OF THESE PROTESTERS ARE ARM
SO YOU HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR BLOODSHED, THE
POTENTIAL FOR VIOLENCE.
>> Tucker: HEAR THAT, CHAZ
DENIERS?
CHAZ HAS GUNS.
CRACK SPECIAL FORCES TEAMS WILL
EMERGE LIKE NINJAS FROM THE
SHADOWS, YOU MAY NOT EVEN
RECOGNIZE THE SOLDIERS, SOME MAY
LOOK HOMELESS, OTHERS MAY BE
INJECTING NARCOTICS OR
SHOPLIFTING BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE,
THIS ARMY MEANS BUSINESS.
THEY ROLLED OVER THE SEATTLE
POLICE DEPARTMENT, THEY’LL DO IT
TO YOU, TOO, CNN, WATCH OUT.
OUR MAN ON THE GROUND ACROSS THE
DEMILITARIZED ZONE, HE JOINS US.
JASON, THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON, WERE YOU ABLE TO CROSS THE
BORDER TODAY?
>> WELL, I HAVE TO TELL YOU THEY
ACTUALLY REALIZE THAT THEIR
BORDER WAS QUITE POROUS, SOME
COPS WERE ABLE TO GET THROUGH SO
THEY RE-FORTIFIED THE BORDERS
THAT ARE THERE SO THEY CAN KEEP
SOME OF THESE POLICE INVADERS
FROM COMING INTO THEIR NATION SO
IT’S A LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT
THAN USUAL TO GET IN BUT THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY CONFIRMED THAT
THEY ARE IN FACT ARMED AND ARE
KEEPING TRACK OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING IN AND OUT OF THEIR
NATION SO THEY ARE TAKING THEIR
SECURITY VERY SERIOUSLY BUT THEY
ARE OBVIOUSLY ALSO HAVING SOME
PROBLEMS AS YOU JUST SHOWED,
WHAT APPEARS TO BE A FARM THAT
WAS PUT TOGETHER BY MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG, IT LITERALLY LOOKS
LIKE TOPSOIL ON TOP OF GROUND
THAT THEY HAVEN’T EVEN DUG UP
AND THEY REALIZE MAYBE IT’S
GOING TO TAKE A LITTLE BIT
LONGER FOR THEM TO GROW SOME OF
THE FOOD.
THEY HAVE SOME REQUESTS.
THEY’RE LOOKING FOR SOME FOOD,
GATORADE, ALSO CIGARETTES OF
COURSE AND ARE REALIZING THAT
MAYBE THEY DON’T HAVE ENOUGH
RESIDENTS WHO ARE WILLING TO DO
SOME OF THE CLEANUPS OF THE CITY
CAME IN AND CLEAN SOME OF THE
PORTA-POTTIES THAT WERE
DELIVERED BY THE CITY TO THIS
NEW NATION SO SEATTLE IS
STEPPING UP.
>> Tucker: IT SOUNDS MORE LIKE
A REFUGEE CAMP THAN IT DOES A
PROUD INDEPENDENT NATION.
>> LOOK, WHAT INDEPENDENT NATION
HASN’T GONE THROUGH SOME OF
THESE GROWING PAINS?
THEY DON’T REALLY EVEN HAVE A
LEADER, NOW I KNOW WE MENTIONED,
THERE IS SOME CONCERN THAT HE
DOESN’T ACTUALLY REPRESENT
EVERYONE AND IT TURNS OUT THERE
HASN’T BEEN AN ELECTION, MAYBE
THERE WILL BE.
PERHAPS THEY WILL ASK FOR IDs.
WE WILL SEE.
>> Tucker: YOU SAID AT THE
OUTSET THAT CHAZ HAS FORTIFIED
ITS BORDERS.
DID ANYBODY POINT OUT THAT
THAT’S RACIST?
BORDERS ARE RACIST, RIGHT?
>> BORDERS ARE RACIST BUT THEY
ARE PROGRESSIVE SEATTLEITES AND
THEY ARE WOKE.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK YOU BE
ABLE TO GET IN TOMORROW, OVER
THE WEEKEND?
>> THAT’S YOUR PRIVILEGE.
I’M GOING TO TRY TO NOT GET
CONTACT HIGH AS I’M WALKING
THROUGH, SOMEONE ACTUALLY WALKED
UP TO US AND SAID, WHERE CAN WE
SMOKE?
AND I SAID, IT CHAZ, I THINK YOU
CAN SMOKE WHEREVER IT IS YOU
WANT.
>> Tucker: THAT’S THE AMERICA